I'm going to ask you some questions easy
questions sound
good off we
[Music]
go before you came to beautiful
bzou your talent was other people's
business no one cares about that Sam
Spade not
anymore I'm happy to step aside I have a
swell life and yet sadly our pasts are
portable get
down the Algerian Wars come home you
might want to protect yourself with
something more reliable than just your
WS these Army intelligence they want the
boy you're just an American private
Couer which in France gives you by the
same legal Authority he has the right to
catch
up m case the two jobs are one and the
same everyone from the Vatican to French
intelligence to the
CIA is after this
kid this has spoiled my
Tranquility people come to you with
their
problems you're good at fixing
them so the problems keep
coming come the be
[Music]
J